[Musik]
salve meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 wir
befinden uns hier wieder in unserer
kleinen minecraft welt meine lieben
freunde das hier vorne ist ja unsere
hobbit hürde und ich glaube der ein oder
andere der sich die fans kemmer genauer
anguckt wird auch schon sehen dass sich
hier gerade nicht alleine sitze denn
neben mir befindet sich sandra leute ich
gucke einfach nur zu heute und bisschen
kommentieren ist das anders wenn ich
jetzt auch schon antike eingeblendet ich
habe mir gedacht dass ich zehn die heute
einfach mal meine minecraft welt zeigen
und ihr zeigen was sich so schon alles
gebaut habe deswegen sandra für dich
erst mal ganz kurz das hier ist mein
dorf
und jetzt
was machst du da so was denkst du denn
was ich hier mache
ist das so wie sims
nicht ganz also das ist auf jeden fall
mein dorf hier wo uns ein paar
dorfbewohner das sind ein paar leute mit
dem man auch handeln kann gucken das
sind diese leute hier unten
ohne oben links waren sind auch diese
sterne da sind diese teams die da über
den fingern sind
oder nicht ganz so viele menschen aus
wie thaddeus
[Musik]
sowie thaddaeus die sache ist auf jeden
fall dass ich mich hier an diesem
dörfchen niedergelassen habe und ihr
hier selber so ein kleines häuschen
gebaut habe das ist das was ich gebaut
habe so ein bisschen in dem
mittelalterlichen stil ich habe hier
oben so ein paar bieren ich habe hier
kartoffeln angepflanzt und wenn ich rein
laufe habe ich das ein bisschen gemacht
dass man so ein bisschen runter laufen
muss dann habe ich oben ein bettchen
stehen und hier habe ich überall so
fässer mit sachen drin hab ich meine
neffen eine werkbank mein amboss rüstung
ständer und ja auch noch mal warum okay
die täglich aus
lukas warum ist eigentlich alles so
verpixelt dass minecraft ja wir sind
doch mittlerweile 2021 warum ist das so
hässlich ja du bist auch im jahr 2020
herzlich wir werden uns auf jeden fall
heute darum kümmern dass wir meine
hobbit höhle ein bisschen
eine spinne was ist da
hier gibt's übrigens auch schlagartig
christian er das jetzt auf jeden fall
meine hobbys höhle ich habe mich das ein
bisschen an dem film logischerweise der
hobbit orientiert wir fordern wir zum
kleinen eingang hiermit zum feld hier
mit einem feld und dann kann man hier
reingehen das soll so ein bisschen rund
sein dann geht man
mega und noch nie sowas bundes gesehen
jeden fall kann man dann hier zur echten
rechten seite mannschafts mal reingehen
hier ist auch so ein kleiner runde
eingang mit zwei betten mit einem
kleinen lagerfeuer mit zwei kisten mit
bücherregalen rüstung ständer und dann
kann man hier reingehen und hier ist
meine küche und da werden wir heute ein
bisschen weiter daran arbeiten vorgehen
wir allerdings einmal ganz kurz schlafen
legen uns ins bettchen rhein mit einer
fackel hier schön der hand und das was
wir heute machen werden ist was sich ja
gerade schon gesagt habe erst mal um sie
um die küche kümmern ich weiß nicht wie
weit wird kommen werden weil ich heute
auch nicht so viel zeit habe jedoch
möchte ich hier erst mal eine kleine
sitzecke hin bauen dafür benötige ich
nämlich erstmal sandstein treppen sandra
weiss mache weißt du wie man sandstein
treffen crafted
ich weiß entweder an was sandsteine
sowas kräftig keine kraft bier wir haben
auf jeden fall fünf sandstein treppen
noch gerade in unserer kirche gehabt
deswegen werde ich dir halt mal hier
hier und hier hier platzieren denn dass
sie wird unser kleiner sitzbereich sein
und jetzt benötigen wir fichtenholz
falsch erweist wie man fichtenholz
bildschirmen crafted was ist kräften
du nimmst was und macht daraus das
andere naja da macht auch
schön und das als ein tisch sein wie
platziere ich jetzt hier hier hier und
hier und das hier ist jetzt unser tisch
warum schwimmt der in der tür du hast
gar keine schrauben benutzt
sondern laute spinne
das weiß
wo ich habe die ganze zeit spielen lukas
wieder nicht sechs millionen aufrufe
du setzt mich verarschen soll das heißen
nur ist mit falschen oder
peinlich alter
einmal das video in dem ich mich die
ganze zeit orientieren denn wir wollen
natürlich heute auch ein bisschen weiter
vorankommen dafür habe ich hier ziegel
schon vorbereitet mit denen ich mir
einen weiteren blumentopf machen werde
beziehungsweise habe ich hier sogar noch
einen blumentopf dann kann ich hier auch
einen pilz nehmen warum bist du so laut
weil das viel scheiße es
und bist du so dass da ein bisschen
darauf ein ist doch schön hier mit jetzt
mit der sonne
da war
und jetzt soll ich wollen
wir gehen jetzt auf jeden fall wieder
hier rein in meiner küche und jetzt kann
ich hier drauf den blumentopf sätzen
zusammen mit einem pilz dann haben wir
hier so ein bisschen was drin stehen
sieht schön aus oder geiler pilz ich
sehe drei pixel
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir uns allerdings einen
rahmen kräften und für den rahmen
benötigt man leder deswegen zählen die
müssen wir jetzt leider auf die suche
gehen nach türen um eine kuh zu töten
ist das hier eine kommt
weiß ich nicht bei dem pixel erkennt man
das ziel ja nicht was denkst du es dass
sie für ein tier
perfekt wir suchen jetzt auf jeden fast
ein alter das hier ist eine kuh
es tut mir leid ich will eigentlich
keine tiere töten diesem projekt aber
ich brauche halt leder es hat kein liter
gedrückt
kommt hier voll da sind sogar noch mehr
gehört deswegen können jetzt einfach
direkt noch gut hätten ich weiß dass ich
dafür hält in den kommentaren kriegen
werde weil ich die tiere tötet uns
eigentlich machen wollte wenn wir
brauchen halt das leder für die rahmen
und ich weiß nicht wie ich anders wieder
bekommen soll deswegen das tut mir auf
jeden fall sehr herzlich leid die sache
du hast doch freunde hast du gesagt
haben ich kann besser in minecraft als
du wir nehmen jetzt auf jeden fall das
leder packen jetzt hier rein und machen
außenrum stöcker denn damit können uns
jetzt zwei bilderrahmen machen die wache
ist jetzt allerdings dass wir ja
dadurch müssen sondern hier
hast du gesagt endlich ernsthaft eine
hausnummer verwechselte warum klaus
nicht einfach ein haus dann musst du
nicht mehr selber mal
garnicht mal dumm ich plötzlich auf
jeden fall hier vorne jetzt auch noch
ein bilderrahmen drauf so haben wir hier
einen und hier und jetzt können wir
beispielsweise ein hohes rindfleisch
einfach rein legen dann sieht so aus als
ob ich hier auf dem tisch zum großen
crash at und die person wird das gleich
essen in den bilderrahmen
der avatar da kann ich auch kurz was
anderes machen denn ich kann jetzt zwei
birken holzbretter nehmen die hier so
hinlegen dann kriege ich nämlich eine
birkenholz druckplatte und wenn ich
jetzt shift gedrückt halte während ich
vor dem rahmen stehe dann sieht das so
dann sieht das so aus
sieht aus wie ein schneidebrett ja aber
dafür dass es in minecraft ist also man
erkennt schon das ist ein stück fleisch
soll
sich aus dem mund
ich hasse die pixel
ich hasse wir holen uns die vorne jetzt
auf jeden fall so eine kornblume was
auch immer das ist und kräften uns aus
dem siegel die wir noch haben noch einen
blumentopf denn ich mag blumen in dem
projekt ich mag es generell thomas ist
ja hier auch schon ich hab das alles ein
bisschen natürlich gemacht wird auch
rosen sprechen vorne dran und jetzt
können wir mich beispielsweise hier vor
ort auch noch einen hinsetzen mit einer
kornblume transit staus oder nein danke
wir kraft uns jetzt auf jeden fall noch
eine laterne dafür nehmen wir uns hier
oben unsere reisen klub braucht wir
haben ja keine mehr ist allerdings auch
kein problem denn dann kann ich einfach
so und so machen neben diesen blick sie
hier in den kreis und nehme mir nun eine
fackel die ich vorher meiner rechten
hand gehalten habe packe die mitte
bekommt dadurch eine laterne die
benötigen wir gleich jetzt sandra würde
ich allerdings mit dir auch nicht die
ganze folge bauen wollen sondern und das
hab ich noch gar nicht gemacht mir hier
so ein bisschen das dorf anschauen ich
würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal am
start an der start des dorfes ist ja
dort hinten und vielleicht finden wir
das ein oder andere klasse item wie
beispielsweise
kräften
das tier vorne ist auf jeden fall das
erste gebäude des ganzen hauses hier ist
nur eine kiste drin mit brot und
kartoffeln mit einem fichten setzlingen
fahren und noch mehr boot das auf jeden
fall ganz geil ich wohne einfach hier
schon seit keine ahnung wie lange zeit
war aber noch keiner in diesen gebäuden
drin hier vorne haben wir auch etwas und
zwar ein kürbiskuchen okay das ist
perfekt sein ich weiß warum wir nämlich
den kürbiskönig service gibt
sprachenlernen batterien kürbiskuchen
können wir jetzt auf jeden fall nehmen
und dient hier vornherein packen dann
sieht es nämlich so aus als ob wir hier
vorne einen kuchen gebacken hätten oder
so das eichenlaub nehmen jetzt einfach
mal platzieren ist hier und hier so dass
wir auch hier in den ecken so ein
bisschen was natürliches haben ich habe
hier gerade die druckplatte kaputt
gelaufen aufgefallen also tatsächlich
noch ganz kurz ran und jetzt hier noch
eine laterne damit es ein bisschen
heller ist und dadurch bis zu berühmt
geworden
durch die scheiße ja peinlich
ich mal ehrlich alter du kannst gar
nicht stolz auf dich sein
zwei leder ok perfekte haben zwei liter
bekommen wir brauchen nämlich genau noch
zwei die dafür 2 rahmen die ich noch in
meiner küche hängen muss
schön
mach mal ich mache mir jetzt aus meinem
glas noch mal ganz kurz eine glasflasche
denn mit der glasflasche können wir uns
ja
schon mit der glasflasche können wir uns
nun zu unserer
bienenwabe bewegen ich weiß allerdings
nicht mehr wo das ist ich hatte ja
eigentlich vor einiger zeit einen baum
gepflanzt und da war dann plötzlich
seinen bienen es dran wenn ihr wisst wo
das mal dann schreibt er gerne in die
kommentare deswegen würde ich die ware
glasflasche jetzt einfach mal so daran
packen an die wand denn das ist
natürlich auch deko noch immer für
unsere küche die beiden bilderrahmen
platziere ich jetzt nämlich einfach mal
so bei den sand treppen dass hier einer
ist und hirt und anpacken hier
beispielsweise eine süße rein und hier
eine glasflasche das hier ist dann auch
schon die fertige küche schlussendlich
das handy für dich einmal ganz kurz
vorgestellt dass ich zu meinen
wasserbecken mit einem handtuch traten
dass ihr freund und schubladen hier
vorne kann ich sachen reinpacken in die
fässer hier ist ein bisschen öffnen hier
kann ich was packen hier kann ich was
kräften und hier kann ich dann sitzen
was ist kräften kraft ist wenn man in
minecraft quasi stirbt also warum hast
du dann eine tote städte bei den zuhause
habe ich mag das
weiße haus und an der stelle würde ich
das heute wieder entweder lieben freunde
wenn es euch gefallen hat dass ich mal
einen gast hier am start hatte der ich
das mal so ein bisschen hier zeigen
konnte das gerne einen daumen hoch oder
die video da abonniert meinen kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr weitere
videos nicht verpassen wollt morgen
kommt eine nicht lachen stellen spitz
andere online wo wir uns witze
vorgelesen haben lassen und dann hat mir
wasser im mund und muss uns anspucken
und keine ahnung was also wenn ihr sehen
wollt dann schaut er morgen wieder auf
einem kanal vorbei um 18 prozent
ich komme nie wieder zu diesem meinen
körper